How do you get better at small talk?
Because as an introvert,
it can be hard work.
I'm going to talk about the three things
that you probably haven't heard of of how
to make small talk feel easy, effortless,
and kind of like all the naturals do it.
small talk as an introvert
is one of the hardest things to get over
because it just sucks.
I want to go deep.
I want to jump in.
I want to skip the foreplay.
But you can't.
Not in this society.
There's a lot of people
who need something more.
And so I went on a little bit of research
to find out what is it?
How do you actually get better at Small
talk?
And I came up with these three things.
That's
what I'm going to share in this video.
Stick around for number three.
I promise
that one is the most important one.
And it took me forever to learn it because
I thought only one and two mattered.
But it's more than that. So here we go.
Number one, It's the belief
that anybody has common interest with you.
It's the belief
that there's always something in common
between you and another person.
It doesn't matter how different they are,
doesn't matter who they are.
There is always something in common in
your job is to be that bloodhound,
to get after the scent
and find that thing that you,
as human beings on this spinning
rock, have in common with one another,
and reframing it as it's always possible
and there's always
something is much, much better than man,
I don't like this dude.
This dude's kind of bumming me out.
Don't have anything in common.
No, you do, but you have to find it.
And that leads us to tip number two.
How do you find it?
Well,
you got to find the why behind the what?
So they like tennis and you like reading.
Maybe they're two different things,
but there is a reason
that they like what they like.
And you like what you like.
Can you find the why behind the what?
Maybe they like reading
because it puts them in a state of flow
and the world
can kind of disappear for an hour.
Which is exactly why I love tennis,
because I can just get on the court
and just be in the zone.
And for one hour nothing else matters.
And maybe that
feeling of I just want to escape
for a little bit and be in my own bubble.
Hey, maybe that's what we have in common
as introverts, I don't know.
Find the why behind the what.
Video games
and cooking are two different things,
but maybe it's all about feeling
immersed in an activity.
You always have something in common
with somebody.
As long as you start to find out
why people do what they do.
Simon Sinek has that great Ted
talk on this.
Start with why.
But it doesn't just apply to business
and marketing.
It's a basic human fundamental idea
that it's not about what we do.
It's about the motivations that drive
the things that make us human.
But what that
leads to is asking a lot of questions,
being curious.
These are all great things,
and we know this.
However, we can fall into a trap
where all we do is ask questions,
be curious, get to know,
keep, keep probing, keep asking.
And by the end of the night, you've
learned so much about the other person.
They haven't learned anything about you.
Does that sound familiar?
Because that's been my life for ever.
And it's frustrating
because what if somebody else isn't?
A great question
asker isn't curious about you?
I start to feel like, man,
I put in all that legwork.
Come on, let's let's make it 5050.
But not everybody is like that.
And that's why it's so important.
Tip number three own your interests.
You got to deliver.
You got to bring yourself
to the conversation
and talk what you want to talk about.
That's the hardest thing for me
is to actually say, you know what
that reminds me of a book I'm reading
and let me tell you about it
without asking, without without requesting
permission, I'm just going to decide.
We're going to talk a little bit
about what
I want to talk about,
and I'll get some feelers out.
if you want to enjoy speaking, then
you got to speak about what you enjoy.
It's the only way.
Small talk for it
to be really something you like.
You got to like talking about something
you enjoy, like
it's got to also fulfill you.
So talk about the video games, talk
about the book you're reading.
Talk about what you saw on TV last night,
bring up stuff
you enjoy because you never know.
Other people might enjoy it too,
and it might spark
even more interesting direction.
So take that confidence
and own your own interest.
Don't just be curious about other people.
That's what most introverts tend to do.
Also, have the courage to assert yourself
and bring up
some conversation topics of your own
that you want to talk about.
Those are the three tips, and hopefully
your small talk will get better
with a little bit of practice.
Just remember to own your interests
because it's hard for us
introverts to do it,
but it's going to pay off in the end.
Thanks for watching!
Please subscribe
and I'll see you next time.